hi everyone I'm going to talk about a
couple of tools that I've been working
on and how they help you bundle your
front-end web applications with HTTP two
so a couple things I'm uncover is just a
rough intro on how server push actually
works not the basics of HTTP to I'm
assuming a familiar with that or there's
other talks to explain that better and
then there's two demos that I want to
show the two projects that i mentioned
one is going to help you reduce latency
and save bandwidth so therefore
accelerate your websites and the other
one is going to help you a transpile but
particularly for projects that are being
served with HTTP server push it's
produced over push is basically adding
bundling like you would do with a web
pack or browserify all these things into
the protocol layer it's a introduces a
new semantics into the protocol most of
the other stuff in HP two is really just
the same as HTTP 1.1 but better so you
get marginal improvements in performance
but would a to b to server push you can
achieve much greater advantages so lots
of different little little uh you know
pros and cons up my plusses for a server
push over the legacy file concatenation
I guess you'd call it so its native in
the browser so the browser can optimize
it it works for any file and not just
JavaScript or CSS or images it just
works blindly across it all you can cash
individual files and update just those
ones rather than an entire bundle and it
works on a foot on the very first
request so you don't have to like load
the HTML and then serve your
concatenated file you can serve
everything from the straight from the
first response all right and you know
falcon combination we're all familiar
with some of the problems that it has so
i want to show you basically how a
server push request flow goes real quick
so you get a request coming in from a
browser to your web server let's say for
/ for the home
page what's going to happen is your
observer is going to analyze that and
say okay you know if you're looking for
the home page you're probably gonna need
a fab you con as well so I'm going to
serve you a fake request because that's
what a promise is it's a fake request
not just a response with a request first
and it's going to say I'm going to put
it on another HP to stream HP has lots
of different streams they all go over
the same socket but just keep that a
concept in mind but it can push lots of
lots of different promises right lots of
different requests I did anticipating
the client to make finally it's going to
serve the actual response to the
original request it's going to serve the
headers in the body and then once that's
once the browser has that it's going to
start pushing all those promises so now
it's serving the responses to these
requests that it pretended occurred so
those I'll go over it over the wire and
we've got a lot of these streams going
on independently so you can prioritize
things you can schedule things it's
pretty cool so let's see what we can do
we've got a tool called HTTP to server
and let's do a little demo see what
happens if we try to sum in comparison
to previous practices I've taken one of
Simon Swain's epic projects from last
year's conference and I want to see how
how fast it works with HB 2 versus hp1
concatenation here on the left-hand side
I've got a browser simulating a
connection from Singapore to San
Francisco that's roughly you know 300
milliseconds of artificial latency but
I've got a gigabit connection because
Singapore's pretty good like that but
what's going to happen with this latency
if we run a server that serves the HTTP
one version of the project which has a
lot of jobs with clouds and some CSS and
then we load that page that extra
latency is going to force a lot of round
trips so we've seeing this graph here
this traditional waterfall the green
parts are basically the latency on the
network there's very little time
actually transferring because I've got a
gigabit right but the latency is going
to kill my app look at that so it's
taking like four seconds all right so
let's see what happens with HTTP two if
I runnin HP to server I'll have to do is
this and by the way to the HP to server
it's blind to any kind of file type so i
don't have to configure you know
complicated gulp script or a web pack
config it just serves everything in
pushes it very easy so let me turn off
this cpu monster all right and go over
to the HP to site run that and see what
happens it's got its got one or cuts and
it's pushing tons of files all those
requests are now getting pushed how long
did I take about the same oh that's not
good right so why is that so there's a
lot of that it goes up if you look at
this left here is excruciatingly Lee
slow right you get a request and then
you know if a vivir con takes 100 5
milliseconds what's hell so this server
is optimizing your files with you know
complicated compression that takes about
a hundred times longer than gzip so it's
not meant to be streaming so when you
start the server it's gonna have a cold
cash when you're running this again and
again it's going to start warming up the
cash you know keeping all these assets
in memory and a compressed State and
eliminate all of that so let's say we
clear the log the server is still
running and we can go back caching is
disabled you can see and run it again
BAM how fast was that right so
everything is now like you know 0 0 1
millisecond and on the network it took a
second so we're three times faster just
eliminating all the latency that's what
server push will do you get one shot of
latency that's the minimal amount of
latency that you're going to have to
accept because that's just your network
but everything else can be eliminated
with HP server push rest concatenation
cannot do this so all right that's
pretty good result let's talk about how
that actually works go back so our page
load time is really a function of
latency and bandwidth there's a it's
called a bandwidth delay product if you
wanna look this up you know basically
the product of your data link capacity
that's like your aggregate band was like
a gigabit per second and your round trip
time measured in seconds would be you
know point three seconds from here to
you know west coast of us this is called
the long fast networks I'm not sure it's
called 11 or elephant I like elephants
so I'm going to call it elephants and
this is a common case for most people
around the world nowadays that you have
a data center that's around the world
and you yourself have a very
high-powered mobile device and you're
probably on a pretty speedy 4G
connection or beyond going forward and
we need to optimize the latency so how
does a to do that we saw it basically
cuts out your graph
you know left-hand side loads in one
second if you have a lot of latency take
like an order of magnitude more than
that just because requests induce and
compound this latency so that's pretty
sweet what else can we do to eliminate
well the other half the product would be
the bandwidth if you can if you can get
free bandwidth from compression and this
magical thing called cash digests that
will help a lot so let's let's look at
that so I mentioned that we doing this
very fancy compression it introduces a
massive load of you know computational
demand on the server but you know but
caching we can we can avoid you know any
kind of performance impact and the two
codecs that i'm using here zup flea or
zip fly I don't know how it could
pronounce it basically that's compatible
with gzip so any browser that supports
gzip it's going to support this slightly
more compressed version of your output
but if you're using let's say Firefox or
Chrome you can support broadly and
that's going to save significant amounts
of bandwidth now it's only working on
HTTPS if you hadn't if you notice that
in the the demo data showed the HTTP one
version was just you know playing static
web server running on HTTP but the HTTP
two one had to run on HTTPS and one of
the troubles that I think a lot of
developers are familiar with is setting
up like certificates for localhost
development getting the sign adding the
exceptions to your browser to pain so
I've kind of taken care of that it's
when you run HP server the first time
it'll register generator tificate hook
it up to your keychain and your browser
will just have a green secure website
thing it's fantastic so even if you just
use it for that you're gonna have a good
time next we've got cash digests to save
us then say for some bandwidth and this
is huge and this is new to me until like
a month ago I not a computer science
type of person so I didn't know anything
about bloom filters and I was like lord
of the rings gollum coded bloom filters
it's a thing right but basically right
what we're doing is we're telling the
server which files we've already got
cached and we're basically hashing
fingerprinting every file or just the
URL taking a couple of bits from that
sticking them all together into a little
header and telling the server here this
is these are the files we have anything
y'all anything that matches that that
you're trying to push me just don't push
it so essentially we're skipping all of
the unnecessary files that haven't
changed since the last time I visited a
page he
savings because most of times not your
entire app is changing tiny parts of
your code base incrementally evolve but
most of the libraries and frameworks
they're not changing all the time so
that's basically how it works that's
what it's meant to do there's a speck
pretty recent from this year that's
doing this all over HTTP frames I'm
using because if the browser knee
support that natively I'm using a
service worker for Chrome and Firefox
and a cookie fallback so it works on
every single browser right now which is
pretty cool so we save a lot of
bandwidth and we save a lot of latency
whether i do because all these round
trips are now eliminated so second tool
that I've got for you is called unbundle
and I'll show you a little demo of that
as well this is going to help you with
the front-end development side of things
everyone's familiar with the JavaScript
fatigue so let's let's set up a little
imaginary tiny little hello world
project so we know we want to use proper
tools we've got react framework from NPM
which is awesome and p.m. i mean i'm not
really react whatever each their own and
I've got a minimalist application
javascript HTML and there we go so what
do we normally do we set up a web pack
build or a gulp thing or you know who
knows what right it's a lot of work
let's cut all that short and say
unbundle and it's going to run but you
know this this computer has about the
power of most people's phones if you
bought them this year but yet it's going
to be pretty quick right the reason is
that it's doing all this stuff in
parallel so I've got two cores in here
no to physical cores so he's going to
run you know parallel builds on this and
it's tracing all of the files that we
have which is all mostly react obviously
this is one one of my own files and
probably 170 files from react it
processed them all and then we run HTTP
to server and we're going to host that
website maybe not okay I gotta kill the
I don't give me a second here we go okay
port issues
here we go so we're running our server
now and serving the files that we just
created that's the static files and
because these commands have nothing
inherently to each other but they just
assume you know sensible defaults so
they kind of work well together you
could use either one without theater so
let's clear our browser no tricks up our
sleeves and see what happens if we load
our app okay like I said the first time
the caching meets the load okay well it
worked so we've got our es6 app we've
got node modules it's all working it's
pretty sweet and if we look at the log
we can see there's a lot going on here
what is that right but really we're
using push just like before with the
static cold war demo here we've got one
request coming in at the top this get
for the homepage and then we're just
going to push app GS and a lot of emoji
that's kind of interesting we'll talk
about that but a lot of these node
modules is you're going to push
individually rather than like a web pack
bundle everything in one in one blob
it's all happening individually and at
the end here does a service worker
that's got something to do with the cash
digests so that's kind of sweet let's
let's jump back into the slides so this
tool is all based on you know really
incredible technology browser 54
dependency tracing battle for doing a
lot of the processing you know mapping
the file paths and then finally using
system jas behind the scenes to
asynchronously load things in the
browser you're not actually interacting
with these tools any more reps tracting
over them and building the next
generation of tools for frontal
development it's got a lot of stuff
built in batteries included it's
minified you got your source maps for
your development and you've got all this
latest syntax available for yourself to
use normally this takes a lot of time I
know I took a lot of time to learn all
these things and set it all up now it's
very easy like I said it's very it's
going to be very fast especially if you
like quad core or going forward or
you're running this on a build server
with like I mean it maybe have like 32
cores on your bills or your builds going
to be lightning fast it's got a watch
mode as well for incremental build
sticks milliseconds right happening in
parallel it's pretty sweet all right
like I said we're using service works
using service workers that means it's
got some little JavaScript running in
the browser right it's like having a CDN
on the clients machine the same it's
using the cache API which is kind of a
misnomer like it the more I started
using it i'm more i figured out that
this isn't really for caching it's kind
of just a key value storage for requests
and responses doesn't have any kind of
complicated and if you have to have to
implement all of the HTTP caching logic
from scratch which isn't something
everyone should be doing I feel so you
can rely on something like that that's
been that's already prepared to take
care of that without errors now
cache-control immutable is another
recent spec that came out this year and
it's going to tell the browser to never
invalidate an asset that's kind of cool
right if you have a asset that you
guaranteed to never change like your
file revving it you should your browser
should isn't even going to check if it's
you know out expired until that max age
has a past but if you set like a file
rift asset to expire in 10 years your
browser is never going to be even doing
round trip at all you can guarantee that
you can rely on that and your servers
wrkn is going to read it from cache put
it in a digest your server is never
going to push that file ever again so
you save huge bandwidth of course you
have to be careful with that so I'm only
applying as the reft files now those
emoji and the file names what's up with
that well this is my solution to cache
invalidation which is the hardest
problem in computer science and I think
I'm owed your the solution to most hard
problems i'm using x.x hash 64 which is
really really fast fingerprinting
algorithm and then encoding that in
emoji right because it's just bits and
why not you know hex is so lame so you
stick an emotion there we need to change
your file is going to come up with the
new emoji and to the browser it's all
transparent this works you know I'm
surprised there wasn't actually any
serious issues with this many tools
showed us to some people and they liked
it as well so that's my two projects and
I hope you enjoy them I enjoyed working
on them and I think this is the future
thank you
you